- [Narrator] “Goosebumps”
is one of the best selling
book series of all time.
And this man is responsible for each
and every terrifying,
spine-tingling, horror-filled story.
- Hi, I'm R. L. Stine.
I write the “Goosebumps” books.
- [Narrator] Huh, maybe he's not so scary?
- [Author] I actually
started as a humor writer.
- [Narrator] Well, what do you know?
In 1992, Scholastic released
the very first “Goosebumps” book,
but way before that,
the young Bob Stine was
into writing jokes.
- I started writing funny stuff
when I was nine years old.
All I ever wanted to be was funny.
When I came to New York, I
had my own humor magazine
and after 10 years I
thought, "Gee, I've done
"what I always wanted to do.
"I guess I'll coast the rest of my life."
I had no idea what was in store for me.
- [Narrator] And then,
things started to get spooky.
- I had lunch with the editorial
director at Scholastic.
She'd had a fight with a YA horror writer
and she said, "You could
write a good YA horror novel."
I said, "Okay, no problem, you got it."
And I went home and wrote this novel
and it was a number one best seller.
I thought, "Oh, wait a minute,
forget the funny stuff."
And I've been scary ever since.
- [Narrator] That book marked
the start of R. L. Stine's
horror writing career.
And he eventually wrote an
entire series called “Goosebumps.”
But it wasn't an immediate success.
- They went out and they
just sat on the shelves.
They didn't sell.
Two months goes by, three months, nothing.
We figured that's it, didn't work out.
And then something happened.
It's a mystery.
Kids discovered it somehow.
Nobody knew me really.
There was no hype, no
advertising, no publicity.
There was nothing.
Just kids telling kids.
It was just, you know,
one of these amazing,
lucky things that happened.
- [Narrator] Now after 25
years, “Goosebumps” is scaring
a whole new generation of kids.
- It's a really nice
thing to be able to write
for different generations.
At first I was shocked when
adults starting showing up
at my book signing.
I'd say, "What are you doing here?"
They'd say we loved you when we were kids.
And I realized I'm nostalgia to them.
I think you kind of
remember that tingle of fear
that you had when you were a kid.
- [Narrator] But with the
success of “Goosebumps,”
does R. L. Stine ever miss
the chance to be funny?
- There's something weird with my brain
because horror always makes me laugh.
It's the same visceral reaction.
That's what I try to do in my books.
People think if you're a horror writer,
you're scary all the time and
your whole life is horror,
but I did my own late night comedy show
at Upright Citizen's Brigade last year.
- [Interviewer] Are you
doing one this year, too?
- I'm waiting by the
phone, no one's called me.
I don't know, I'm waiting.
That was it, that might
be my comedy career.